you guys probably thought I forgot about
this one hey what is up guys MTV HD here
and this is the HTC u12 plus so HTC has
had a couple really interesting years
leading up to this new phone and this
turns out to be one of the only
flagships available in 2018 with no
knotch and a couple super unique
features and the other thing is in the
US or anywhere really this phones not
going to be in stores that may explain
why you or someone you know hasn't
really heard of this or you're hearing
about it for the first time not as much
hype around the sky but it will be
available online for 849 bucks so that's
definitely high-end it's a premium
flagship so is it worth your money well
first of all just as far as design this
is the translucent blue color it's the
only color of this phone I consider
buying it in as you can see that the
glass is a little bit see-through in the
top half which I love it's not quite
jerry-rigged everything fully seeing all
the components see-through but it's
still pretty unique and I'm a fan of
this I'd love to see other phones offer
something similar to this too there are
some other colors available for this
phone as well but they aren't
see-through so who cares about them but
this is the glass back enabling this of
course so the whole back of the phone is
now this glass it's much slipperier but
there's no wireless charging so if you
hated one plus we're going glass back
but no wireless charging then you have
to paint this one too but bottom line I
am a big fan of the way this one looks
even though it does catch plenty of
finger prints I think it is one of those
where I would just not ever put a case
or a skin on it just leave it the way it
is the rest of this phone looks pretty
normal though for 2018 you know pretty
simple design lots of HTC cues and shape
but you wouldn't suspect anything to
stand out crazy just looking at it but
there are actually a lot of really
interesting things about this phone
first of all the squeeze is back and
it's like leveled up it still has the
side squeeze sensitivity from the U 11
so you can set a shortcut to launch
something when you squeeze the phone but
also have different types of squeezes so
a quick squeeze is one thing and a long
squeeze is a different shortcut and on
top of that you have pressure
sensitivity all the way up the side
the phone so while you're holding it if
you double tap the side of the phone
with your thumb it acts as a shortcut to
one handed mode and if you switch hands
and DoubleTap with the other thumb
that's the other side shrinking to
one-handed mode so a lot of hand
gymnastics but it's being really smart
about what it does with that pressure
sensitivity so that's pretty impressive
when it works it's not always perfect it
can get pretty finicky and sometimes I
tried an outright doesn't work and
there's a lot of ghost taps and it can
fix itself after a while but basically
the only downside has been that it
doesn't always sense the tap but then on
top of all of that the most interesting
part about this phone might not be the
color might not be the
pressure-sensitive squeezed feature it's
that this phone doesn't actually have
any real buttons the power button and
volume button on the side of this phone
aren't normal clicky actuating buttons
there are even more pressure sensitive
areas on the side of the phone so when
the phone is often you press the volume
buttons they don't move you know kind of
like apple's solid-state touch ID home
button it's not an actual button until
the phone turns on and when it is on
there's a vibration motor that kicks in
and simulates the feel of pressing a
button when you squeeze or put pressure
on that area so okay how have these fake
buttons played out in real-world use
well like I said the best version of
this would be Apple's haptic engine
where have you pressed the home button
on an iphone eight you're fully
convinced usually that you're clicking
an actual button it still feels like
you're pressing something that clicks
this is a decidedly average vibration
motor inside so it's not nearly as
convincing I've gotten used to it I
expect it now when I press the button to
have that feeling but it's it's it's way
worse there's definitely a slight delay
like when I press the home button versus
when I actually feel the vibration that
is supposed to simulate a click there's
a slight delay that makes it feel
software driven rather than like the
haptic engine being exactly when I click
it that's the difference it doesn't feel
as real and it becomes really obvious
when you try to double press any of
these buttons like double tapping the
power button doesn't do anything double
tapping the volume buttons doesn't raise
the volume twice you have to really
press it slowly to actually get it to
work and this is not fun at all this is
not a good experience I think for some
people this can be a deal-breaker in
this phone I personally still do
prefer really good clicky buttons and I
think I'll continue to praise them until
haptic engines get way better but this
is probably the biggest downside of this
phone okay another unique thing about
this phone you may have already noticed
the dual cameras on the back but you
also get two cameras up top here at the
front - selfie cameras and these are
just for portrait mode selfies and I was
hoping I was hoping one of them would be
a regular camera and one of them would
be a super wide-angle selfie camera so
you could take super wide angle selfies
without having to do some corny
stitching effect but no this is just the
same focal length slightly separate from
each other to do better blur and bokeh
for portrait mode the actual bokeh
effect isn't actually any better than
average I don't think something like a
pixel or a galaxy s 9 or an iPhone are
still hit or missed the same way this
one is with hair and faces but it does a
decent job the main advantage which we
also see with Samsung with a single
camera but the main advantage is you can
control the amount of background blur
after you take the photo so that's nice
plus all the other interesting stuff
HTC usually throws in the selfie camera
they're kind of like Samsung they feel
they need to go crazy with beauty mode
there are many different things you can
do to your face in beauty mode but you
may or may not ever use those but yeah
those are the main unique things about
the zone that may not be obvious from
the second you pick it up I'd say the
rest of this phone is normal for 2018
it's a flagship that checks a lot of
boxes it has high-end specs and a pretty
conservative but likable design its IP
68 water-resistant which is great the
fingerprint reader is on the back in the
middle again right where it should be
excellent use of space high it has a
micro SD card expansion slot and it
really has a lot of what people have
been asking for no notch
thin side bezels great build great
display high-end specs quality camera
etc the only thing that's really missing
is the headphone jack even the dual
speakers are a nice upgrade that's not
boom sound or anything but it's the one
at the bottom plus the earpiece doubles
as a front-facing channel so you're not
gonna accidentally block your audio very
easily with this setup and they do get
loud and sound full and then it has a
thirty five hundred million power
battery which sounds like it should be
plenty but it's definitely not it could
have something to do with the display so
it is a 6 inch 28 80 by 1440 Super LCD
panel will work it has something to do
with H
see software but I'm basically barely
getting a day out of it when I thought
I'd be getting a day-and-a-half
easily it charges quick and that's nice
there's no wireless charging like I said
but that's not a deal-breaker for me I
just wish the battery life was better to
begin with maybe software can be
improved maybe a software update can
actually make that better so that just
leaves us with the software and the
camera
the software is HTC Sense so it's about
what you'd expect and the camera is
pretty good so HTC Sense UI is on top of
Android 8.0 Oreo and hopefully with
Android P coming very soon and I've
never had a problem with HTC Sense
really it's never been my favorite skin
on top of Android but it's also been
pretty tame for a while you still have
blinkfeed to the side of the homescreen
you still get all these fancy looking
icons with these shadows now and
everything there is a customizable
second panel next to the navigation bar
for shortcuts which is pretty cool but
you can't add app shortcuts I wish I
could add a custom app down there if I
wanted but that would have been even
cooler
they added face unlock which everyone
seems to be doing now but I still prefer
this phones fingerprint reader which is
great and there's even a smart rotate
feature which I love which keeps the
phone in portrait mode at all times when
it knows it's being gripped in portrait
mode but lets it rotate when it's not
being gripped that way I think that's
really cool so it's mostly what you're
used to from HTC here pretty quiet just
tossing in a couple things here and
there over the last couple years you can
still phim it but there's no radical
design changes here it's it's about what
I expected and then on the back the
camera or cameras like I said are pretty
good so you're getting a 12 megapixel
main shooter with F 1.75 aperture with
optical image stabilization and your
secondary is a telephoto 16 megapixel
shooter f 2.6 with no OIS and the photos
I've been taking they're not quite the
best in any smartphone but they do fit
right in here with I would say a top 5
good detail and color and even a shallow
depth of field and a kind of nice
looking bokeh if you get shallow enough
I think the cameras biggest flaw is that
it tends to overexpose making things a
little bit too bright and you'll notice
it doesn't have the best dynamic range
so you might lose a little bit of
highlights but overall I'm sure
automatic metering can be adjusted and
you can always do manual metering easily
with slider
so I'm just being picky I think this is
a sneaky top five smartphone camera
right now I think right now you're clear
top dogs are pixel to iPhone ten and
then this falls right in line with like
Galaxy S nine and I'd say better than
one plus six so yeah overall right now
is a packaged HTC u12 plus is a flagship
worthy of your consideration
you know it's SPECT like a flagship it's
definitely built like a flagship and
it's price like a flagship but as an
overall package it feels like this this
phone is like almost there it's it's I
mean I guess if you're a super anti
notch if you're one of those people that
left a comment saying this phone has a
notch so I'll never buy it then I guess
your choices are like this and galaxy s
9 because this is one of the few phones
without enough but other than that this
phone legit checks a lot of boxes with a
thumbs up and really only fall short in
the buttons and the battery life like
these buttons I'm just barely okay with
like I'm used to them now but I feel
like I'm not gonna be happy about them
in two or three years but they are what
they are but it's the subpar battery
life you got to think about and that
experience that all comes with it and I
think HTC is not always tops or first to
update their phones to the new OS but
fingers crossed they get to Android
peace soon like they seem to have
promised counting on you guys anyway
that's it that's HTC u12 plus you think
you could rock a phone with no real
buttons let me know what you think in
the comments below I'll be hanging out
there answering questions of course as
usual thank you for watching
doc together the next one peace